who is Mickey Thomas Mickey Thomas is
the guy from the Jefferson Airplane ship
from the starship whatever I can't keep
it all straight Mickey come in look at
you oh you still look good look at you
look at you man hey Jeff what do you do
amen thank you Jeff the guitar play see
I know that okay take a seat Mickey how
are ya
Mickey of course was with the starship
and Mickey had the biggest hits with the
starship you went there the van was
losing money wasn't making any money
anymore it was a dead issue you come in
you front the band which is exciting the
thing takes off did you write some of
those hit songs too yeah you know I
co-wrote some of them right and we were
lucky because some you know the
chemistry did work somehow because you
know when I did first joined the band in
79 you know Marty Balin and Grace Slick
and both left right it's like how can
this van carry on now Marty and grace
have both gone weren't gonna do and they
wanted you know the rest of the guys
wanted to keep on going so so then you
know they called me and we got together
and hung out and jammed a little and
wrote some songs and talked and I
thought I don't know if this is gonna
work how'd they find you they just heard
about you someone I think because of my
Elvin Bishop band age right fooled
around and fell in love they you know
who sang fooled around and fell in love
I just found that out so you didn't know
that no I didn't yeah make you some
fooled around and fell in can you do a
little that yeah
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
be cold as a stone
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
yeah
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
yes repay
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
oh man that's let me tell you where the
genius in that time that is great it's
in that pause yes so crazy in that pause
that's good man